he wanted to play a superhero uh yeah I
wanted to play anything didn't you
audition for Captain America did I
audition for a more I had a rough run
which ones tell me which ones you
auditioned I auditioned for Thor but not
even to be Thor but to be one of like
the sidekick guys and I didn't get a
call back it got to the point where I
was never gonna audition for Marvel
again I was like this is stupid I'm
never gonna be in a Marvel which other
ones you got to tell me anything that
came out that needed a guy that even
remotely looked like me I auditioned for
in some way or another I would either
submit a tape and then they would say no
we don't need to see him or I would get
there and see them and they'd go nah
that's the last time we need to see you
and it was not only just marble things
PC characters not DC characters but like
you know I a Star Trek or uh Avatar or
uh you know anything it was like
this guy walks in and he's got the it
Factor yeah over and over again I was
like well I definitely don't have that
in Factor they're looking for because
they don't even want me to come back
turned out you do have the hits
Star Wars